so the dot was on a monday on thursday
was my regular uh there was a regular
day when i listened to shortwave
transmission every thursday
for 10 years at 9 15. okay and what was
the purpose of this well that was when
that was how they communicated with me
oh okay i never met
another agent uh i never met my handler
in the united states you know you see
that in the movies doesn't didn't happen
with us okay it was forbidden
was too dangerous
anyway uh so i'm i'm dialing the
frequency i'm listening i decrypt the
message and it says
in so many words uh we have reason to
believe that the fbi is investigating
you
uh you know let's start start emergency
procedures immediately uh
blah blah blah and that was the end
okay so reason to believe they weren't
really convincing they didn't tell me
exactly what the reason was so i thought
there was some hope
and i was still paying for time i was
still trying to figure out what to do
what to do
and
i also
started
some
to take some measures to
find out whether i'm being under
investigation there's somewhere some
some things that you can do in your
apartment where you
when something is moved that people when
they look through stuff that is not in
the same space anymore it's the same
stuff that you were that was you were
trained no no no i made that up you know
okay okay there wasn't but but i was
trained to do one thing and and i did
that too
to find out how
your mail is being opened
so you you uh
you write a letter to yourself with a
fictitious address
and you know write something in there
and when you close the envelope you
don't
you leave blank spaces in the glue
all right so you close it and but
there's a couple of spots maybe an inch
each where the wood isn't glued
because the generally male is opened by
machines and then it's closed
automatically with machines so when when
you get this letter and it's fully glued
you know you got a problem
wow okay wow and one other thing is i
did you know i uh i was extremely well
trained to find out whether somebody's
following me
so i took a day off and i was wondering
and wandered around in new york city
and i
saw absolutely no sign that anybody was
following me
and and because i got feedback
in my training in moscow from from
the the the head of this this department
that guy was really really good he said
he gave me a compliment he said i was
one of the best he ever worked with
so that gave me
more certainty that
they may be wrong
so at least gave me more
time to to to play for time because at
this point the the kgb didn't know that
i received the messages i could have
been in a hospital right
or my radio was broken right
um
because one time i actually had a
an injury and for like three weeks i
could not do anything my because my
right arm wasn't a sling
but then they
went to the extreme and did something
that they normally wouldn't do so on my
way to work there was again it was a
a dark
summer i'm a winter morning i'm waiting
for the a train on the elevated platform
and from my right comes
uh a short man in a black trench coat
and he comes really close
there weren't too many people around it
was early in the morning and he whispers
in my ear
you gotta come home
or else you're dead
and then he walked away
now
people think it was a threat
maybe twenty percent but eighty percent
chance was that you know he was a
russian he spoke with an accent he
didn't quite understand what that phrase
means
you're dead you don't say it in this
context because then it could be taken
literally i can say to you you know if
you if you do this you're dead it means
you could lose your job right it's a
it's a metaphor right or whatever you
want to call it so uh it seems like you
just didn't want to believe you just
didn't i didn't want to believe that
this was a threat
it could have been but uh whatever uh
but here's the point now
they knew that i knew
so there was no more
playing for time
uh in the next radio and the next radio
transmission
they uh um
called me to uh implement a dead drop
operation that's when
when somebody drops something over there
that that has
maybe money or a passport in it some
kind of a container and you will pick it
up that's
that's the real short description right
and they were actually they changed the
emergency procedure they were going to
me in uh
to to give to me in an old rusty rusty
old oil can
travel money on a passport
to get out still
across to canada i still hadn't made a
decision
but at least i was going to get the
money right
so and and then then i knew i would have
to make a decision rather quickly
so here's what wha
what happened which is the most odd
thing in my entire
career as a as an agent
uh the uh
the uh operation was in a park in staten
island
uh the spot
where the container was to be placed i
found i described i knew exactly how to
go there
i knew uh and i was told with regard to
uh these types of operations i was also
very good they actually use some of my
descriptions to teach others how to
describe a spot so it can be found
so i and it was this was in the dark
for some reason it's the only time we
did this in the dark
and um
i
i go to staten island and there was a
spot where
a signal was to be placed that told me
uh you can go and get the container i
did it i put it there
the signal was there so i walk into the
park and it was supposed to what type of
signal was it it's a chalk mark okay
real simple
okay um
and i get to that tree with a hollowed
bottom
uh
was really really easy to find and there
was no oil can
i say what the heck's going on here i
did a double take i want it around a
little bit maybe he just like dropped it
and it
it was gone i couldn't i couldn't find
the container
so as i walked away
from that uh failed operation
it said in here
i'm staying
really you see this how
how
imbalanced this was because obviously
there was i was in danger in some way
and if i
disobeyed the the command from the
center i could have been in danger
if
through the kgb right because they i
knew they did not uh treat defectors
very well
and uh you know all the good things for
me
were back behind the iron curtain
the wall hadn't come down yet that took
another year i i just knew that i had a
lot of dollar savings and i had a wife
and a child and and the russians even
promised me once i'm done they promised
to
give me a house which
is was a rarity in in the in the
communist world so everything good was
over there and everything not good was
over here
the only thing
that that was the counterweight was
a smile of an 18 month old girl
and in here it said
i'm staying
and so now the people always ask how did
you how did you do this how did you
manage you know brilliant
it's another thing that just popped into
my head
oh yeah i'm i'm making up a story i i so
i sat down the next day i wrote a letter
in secret writing and told him
unfortunately i can't i can't come
because i have hiv aids
and uh that was
a
as good a lie as
i could have come up with because they
believed it really they had no reason to
not believe it they didn't know i had a
child
they didn't know i was married in the
united states they didn't know any of
this they didn't know what that's what's
going on in my head they all
all they knew this yeah man i get to go
back and uh you know be celebrated as a
hero because my
uh 10 years were considered a success i
the year before i received the second
highest declaration of the soviet union
wow yeah
so they believed it they believed it so
well that they went to my german family
and told them that i had passed away
from this
disease wow i didn't know that they
believed this until i was able to
reconnect with germany that's when i was
told what happened
so for the next three months
i was very careful not to
be predictably in the same spot at the
same time so i would go to work at
different times i would go zigzag
you know i just like
was unpredictable
and after
i had already decided that the fbi
wasn't wasn't
going coming after me and after the
three months
i said
well i'm in the clear now i'm going to
live out my life as an american
i